soon the government will exert
unprecedented control over what
California doctors can say to their
patients about covet 19. we got to stop
the disinformation pipeline essentially
it puts the CDC in the same room with
the doctor and the patient Governor
Gavin Newsom signed ab2098 into law this
September and starting in the New Year
doctors who disseminate what the state
defines as misinformation or
disinformation related to the sarskov 2
coronavirus can face disciplinary action
by the California medical board
including being stripped of their
licenses these are doctors who are
licensed Physicians who carry the same
license as I do who provide legitimacy
to disinformation it essentially ends
your ability to to combat bad ideas put
out by public health because you have
this this looming power or that over you
that essentially can end your career
Stanford Economist and medical school
Professor Jay bhattacharya was one of
several scientists whose work NIH
director Francis Collins said needed a
quick and devastating published takedown
in an email to Anthony fauci that was
obtained through a foia request
batacharya was one of the scientists
behind the Great Barrington declaration
in October 2020 open letter calling for
an immediate end to the lockdowns and
use of an alternative covid-19
mitigation strategy called focused
protection Collins called bhattacharya
who was a professor of medicine
economics and health policy at Stanford
a fringe epidemiologist along with his
co-signers Harvard's Martin kuldorf and
Oxford universities Dr sunetra Gupta
this kind of campaign essentially put
the government in the role of of
suppressing legitimate public policy
debate Public Health debate about what
the right strategy ought to be they put
their finger on the scale
the idea was to create this illusion of
consensus around the lockdowns that
didn't actually exist which was I mean I
think quite dangerous and led to
tremendous bad outcomes for people all
around the world
um I I think it's very dangerous for
public health to think that it has a
monopoly on the truth but acharya says
that same illusion of consensus is what
California lawmakers are leveraging to
quash dissent among doctors across the
entire state the law defines covid-19
misinformation as medical advice
contradicted by contemporary scientific
consensus they'll just not specify how
to define such a consensus regardless of
your views on the state of California's
coronavirus response policies or their
Public Health policies I think any
person left right liberal conservative
who goes to their physician and asks
them a question about covet treatment or
coveted interventions wants to actually
know what their physician thinks they
don't no one wants a Doctor Who's just
reading from a script that was written
by the California Department of Public
Health Aaron cariati is a psychiatrist
and former Professor who taught
bioethics at the University of
California Irvine's medical school he
was fired after he refused to comply
with the University's vaccine mandate
and published an essay critical of the
policy he's also a co-plaintiff in a
lawsuit filed by the new civil liberties
Alliance a non-profit Law Firm that
views the administrative State as an
especially serious threat to
constitutional freedoms
the suit which has yet to be heard is
challenging the California law on the
grounds that it violates free speech and
due process rights science and
censorship are in fact incompatible the
reason is that the scientific Enterprise
and makes progress and moves forward by
conjecture and refutation by generating
a hypothesis and doing a study to
potentially refute the hypothesis it has
to be an ongoing open conversation where
debate where novel perspectives were
challenges to Orthodoxy or conventional
thinking are not only permitted but
welcomed and then tested against the
empirical evidence that's how science
proceeds so trying to fixate whatever
the current consensus happens to be and
and lock it in in law is something that
cannot be challenged by physicians
will stifle the progress of Science and
that's obviously going to be a bad thing
not just for the practice of medicine
but for the advance of Medical Science
and the advance of treatment
recommendations which need to be revised
on an ongoing basis especially for a
novel illness like this that we're still
learning so much about the Bill's
authors didn't reply to our interview
requests but Democratic assemblyman Evan
Lowe had this to say upon introducing
the bill
the definition of misinformation is
malicious intent it is very specific
very direct and it's important that we
help allow the California medical board
to have these definitions in place to
ensure the Integrity of our Health Care
system and provide an opportunity to
save lives what would you say is the
proper role of a medical board how does
it effectively identify you know cranks
or quacks who are legitimately harming
their patients so that's a great
question it's not an easy question
legally I will I will admit that but
historically and as medical boards have
functioned really up until the pandemic
as far as I have seen is that they tend
to give Physicians very wide
discretionary latitude
to make specific medical judgments the
law in California specifies that the
medical board cannot discipline
Physicians for example for engaging in
complementary or alternative medical
practices so long as they have some
level of evidence to support them so you
can do things in medicine that are
outside of the allopathic mainstream and
the medical board cannot discipline you
and that's good for that's good for
patients who want to seek out medical
providers that are doing things
that may be a little bit outside of the
mainstream now those those doctors have
a duty to give the patient the
information on this is what we know this
is what we don't know this is the
evidence or the lack of evidence if
doctors are practicing medicine that
harms patients malpractice laws protect
patients against that
those those laws are are completely
legitimate in my eyes this law what it
does is prevents doctors from dissenting
against reigning ideas in public health
even when public health is wrong
Governor Gavin Newsom added a signing
statement that this bill does not apply
to any speech outside of discussions
related to covid-19 treatment within a
direct physician-patient relationship
but bhattacharya says supporters of the
law hoped to use it to silence doctors
on social media the lawsuit alleges that
one of the groups that lobbied for the
law no license for disinformation whose
Representatives didn't reply to our
interview request regularly threatened
him and other dissenting physicians in
the lead-up to the Law's passage with a
member of the group tweeting at one
plaintiff I look forward to reporting
you to your medical board once a certain
law is passed in California when we
reached out he told us that I hope the
suit gets tossed and they all deserve to
lose their licenses
why did they attack me what's not
because I'm posing any risk to patients
I don't care for patients I I do
research full-time
um they attacked me because the the idea
of the law the real purpose of the law
is to limit dissent against public
health generally by authoritative
figures
especially doctors
during testimony in favor of the bill
the founder of no license for
disinformation pointed not to a
physician practicing medicine but to a
group of doctors who held a press
conference
a group of uh Physicians calling
themselves America's front-line doctors
led by licensed California physician
named Simone gold
um held a pro press conference in what
can only be called the most
uh prolific public showing of
disinformation to date if you've gotten
the virus there's treatment that's what
we're here to tell you regardless of how
one feels about the message put forth by
this particular group of doctors
bhattacharya says that mentioning them
during the debate of the bill is
evidence that the target is not only
physicians in practice but any public
dissent from doctors
although the letter of the law may say
just let's limit what happens in patient
rooms even that's bad enough as we've
already discussed in fact the effect of
the law will be to suppress free
discussion by doctors who are afraid of
losing the license if they disagree with
Public Health Online and elsewhere the
rationale written into the text of the
law is that covid-19 has claimed
millions of lives worldwide including
tens of thousands in California and that
the safety and efficacy of covid-19
vaccines has been confirmed through
evaluation by the federal Food and Drug
Administration it's plausible to say
that it was true at one time but as the
virus has evolved and has as time has
gone on and we have more distance from
the time of vaccination to the infection
that that claim may not be as true
anymore that reasoning also ignores the
fact that a doctor's recommendation has
to be tailored to the needs of this
specific patient in front of
so the All or Nothing claim that
vaccines are safe and effective
Glides over the very significant uh for
example age-stratified differences in
the risks and benefits of the vaccine
Glides over this significant risk and
benefit difference between someone who's
never had covet and someone who's
already had covet and has natural
immunity so it's not necessarily the
case that a Doctor Who's recommending
the vaccine for an 80 year old with
diabetes would also want to recommend
the same vaccine for a six-year-old or a
16 year old or even a 26 year old a law
like this doesn't take account of that
aspect of medical care that needs to be
individualized to the patient teriyadi
says that this law is the latest example
of a trend towards an increasingly
centralized bureaucratic health system
that prioritizes control and
surveillance over individual patient
needs the topic he covers that length in
his book the new abnormal the subtitle
is the rise of the biomedical Security
State which is kind of the melding of
Public Health digital Technologies of
surveillance and police powers of the
state the laws or the or the regulations
that are governing the practice of
medicine and governing people's lives at
ever more subtle levels even though a
lot of these policies have been rolled
back I don't think we've seen the last
of of this kind of movement in this
direction and I think a big part of that
is going to be increasingly sort of
squeezing and compromising Physicians
what I call before Physicians
discretionary latitude their their
ability to make patient-specific
judgments their ability to to think and
to practice medicine according to their
best judgment according to their own
interpretation of research and the
medical literature according to their
own clinical experience
I worry that doctors are increasingly
going to become functionaries in a
larger sort of Public Health apparatus
that doesn't know how to individualize
care to the needs of specific patients
but takes this kind of All or Nothing
approach to managing a problem like
covet what are some of the best ways to
either reverse or at least halt that to
escape the new abnormal
we need to end the declared state of
emergency at the federal level and at
the state levels so here in California
we're still operating under a state of
emergency which gives Governor Newsom
and his appointed Public Health
officials on elected officials extra
Constitutional Powers that they wouldn't
otherwise have outside of the emergency
President Biden announced a month or so
ago in 60 minutes that the pandemic was
over which was true in fact it's been
over for quite some time but many of his
advisors immediately panicked and said
no no you can't say that the reason they
panicked is if it's true that the
pandemic is over then the State of
Emergency the federal state of emergency
which is renewed by HHS secretary Javier
Becerra with the endorsement of the
president and has been renewed every
three months for the last three years
almost that will have to end and when
that happens the 128 additional extra
Constitutional Powers that the president
gains during this declared state of
emergency will have to be relinquished
and the powers that HHS and its its
agencies like the CDC FDA NIH gain will
also have to be relinquished the
emergency use authorizations of the
vaccines no longer apply if we're not
under a state of emergency the Pfizer
and modern Journal vaccines are fully
FDA approved for adult use but an
emergency use authorization still covers
use among minors carriati also favors
decentralizing research funding so that
less of it is directed by federal
officials like Anthony fauci and Francis
Collins at the National Institutes of
Health who can make or break the career
of a scientist by funding or denying
them grant money the lawsuit against
California was filed in November and has
yet to be heard by a judge if no ruling
is issued in the coming weeks
ab2098 will become California law
starting January 1st the fundamental
problem is the loss of authority that in
public health because they have
squandered their Authority to correct
the record rather than being honest
about what was known and not known
calling for more studies when they're
needed to resolve these uncertainties
Public Health should not rule over the
Public Public Health should be partners
with the public in in promoting health I
think humility would be the watchword in
my reform Public Health
[Music]